hello everyone and welcome to some fun
chess trivia I decided to test your
knowledge about everything we've done on
the channel so far so I will give you 10
names of the chess players but not their
actual names I will give you their
nicknames and you have to guess the
player so starting with number one let's
make it an easy one uh the pride and
sorrow of Chess I'm sure we all know who
that is uh number two uh the Austrian
morphe at number three the Black Death
number four a little capablanca or their
Klein and capablanca number five is the
Eternal second number six is the hand
one of the coolest nicknames in chess
ever number seven is Chucky at number
eight is the lightning kid at number
nine the artist and number 10 of course
the magician from Riga now I'm sure this
was very easy for you as this is only
the first trivia I'm doing so
congratulations I'm getting well 10 and
if you actually got all 10 you have uh
you know achieved the bragging rights in
the comments section so there you have
it hope you enjoyed it see you soon